"Pan," the Greek word for "all."
"Theos," Greek for "gods."
"Pantheon," "all the gods."
No one knows why this name was given to the oldest in use building in the world,...
...but maybe it's apt in one respect.
The Pantheon in Rome could be the closest that human creation has come to immortality.
In 2019, nine million people visited the Pantheon.
It was the most visited site in Italy.
The building of today isn't the first Pantheon here.
There were two before it and both burned down,...
...giving rise to the idea that the building was cursed.
The one that stands now was completed circa 125 AD by Emperor Hadrian,...
...who also made this wall, Hadrian's Wall.
But what the Pantheon was used for is far from certain.
One theory suggests it was where the emperor communed with his fellow gods,...
...a coffeehouse for the immortals.
Another claims it was a holy site...
...where Rome's founder, Romulus, ascended to heaven to become the god Quirinus.
This is Pantheon's dome, crowned at its apex...
...with a 30-foot oculus, an opening to the heavens.
The dome is still the largest unsupported concrete dome in the world.
It is also a perfect hemisphere, 142 feet across.
So masterful was the dome that in medieval times,...
...it was considered the work of the devil...
...because no mortal could have created it.
Michelangelo called it angelic, not human.